J.T.
subscribes to a cell phone
texting plan with three other
members of his family.
Within any given month, they
cannot send more than 500 text
messages total.
So they cannot send more than
500 text messages total.
At the end of this month, J.T.
had sent 25 more texts than
his older sister.
Let me highlight.
Let me do this in different
colors.
So at the end of
the month, J.T.
had sent 25 more texts than
his older sister, 50 fewer
texts than his younger
sister, and 125 more
texts than his mother.
How may texts could J.T.
have sent if they did not go
over the 500-text limit?
So let's just define some
variables over here.
Well, let's say o.s.
o dot s is, well let's just say
o, o is for older sister.
So this is number of texts
by older sister.
Let's say that y is equal
to number of texts
by his younger sister.
And then we'll use m is
equal to the number of
texts by his mother.
And we'll use j for a number
of texts by J.T.
So the total number of texts
that everyone sent cannot be
more than 500.
So if we take the sum of J.T.'s
texts, plus his older
sister's texts, plus his younger
sister's texts, plus
his mother's texts, they all
have to be less than or equal
to 500 total texts.
Right, it can't be more than
500, so the sum has to be less
than or equal to 500.
Now, how can we express each
of these in terms of the
number of texts J.T.
sent?
Well, they give us some
information here.
This first statement, J.T.
had sent 24 more texts than
his older sister.
So j is equal to 25 plus the
number of texts of his older
sister, which we say is o.
It's not a 0, that's an
o for older sister.
And they also tell
us that J.T.
sent 50 fewer texts than his
younger sister, so j is also
equal to the younger sister
minus 50, right?
50 fewer texts than his
younger sister.
And then finally, they say 125
more texts than his mother, so
j is equal to mother plus 125.
Now, I want this equation all
in terms of j's, because we
want to say how many
texts could J.T.
have sent.
So I want all of these expressed
in j, so let's just
solve each of these for o in
terms of j, solve for y in
terms of j, solve for m in terms
of j, and then we can
substitute back over here.
So if j is equal to 25 plus o,
if we subtract 25 from both
sides of this equation, we get
j minus 25 is equal to o.
These are the same thing.
If you just take this and
subtract 25 from both sides,
you get that right there.
Now here, if you add 50 to both
sides of this equation,
if you add to 50 to both sides
of this equation, j plus 50 is
equal to the number of texts
that his younger sister sent.
I just added 50 to both sides.
And then over here, if you
subtract 125 from both sides
of this equation-- scroll over a
little bit-- if you subtract
125 from both sides, you get
j minus 125 is equal to the
number of texts sent
by his mother.
And we could have gone
straight here.
This first statement, J.T. has
sent 25 more texts than is
older sister.
So if you take the number
of texts J.T.
sent, subtracted 25, you'd get
the number of texts by his
older sister.
That is an o, it is not a 0.
o for older.
Likewise, he sent 50 fewer texts
than his younger sister,
so if you took the number of
texts he sent, add 50 to it,
you're going to get how many his
younger sister had sent.
And then finally, he sent 125
more than his mother, so if
you took J.T.'s texts, you take
out 125, then that's how
many his mother sent.
So now that we have this, we
can substitute for each of
these variables into the
original equation.
So you have J.T.'s texts, plus
his older sister's texts.
But we know that o is the same
thing as J.T.'s texts minus
25, so we write J.T.'s
texts minus 25.
And then you have plus his
younger sister's texts, but we
know that's J.T.'s
texts plus 50.
And then you have his mother's
texts, but his mother's texts
are just J.T.'s texts minus
125, so plus j minus 125.
And all of that has to be less
than or equal to 500.
So let's add the j's.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4 j's,
so you have 4 j's.
And let's add the constants.
You have a negative 25 plus
a 50, which is 25.
And then you have 25 minus
125, so 25 minus 125 is
negative 100.
So 4j minus 100-- I just added
all the constant terms-- has
to be less than or
equal to 500.
And now this is a pretty
straightforward inequality.
Add 100 to both sides and we get
4j-- these cancel out-- we
get 4j is less than
or equal to 600.
Divide both sides by 4-- don't
have to worry about the
inequality since 4 is a positive
number-- and we get j
is less than or equal to 150.
So J.T.
had to send less than or equal,
he had to send 150 or
fewer texts in that month in
order for all the constraints
to match up and for the family
as a combined unit to send
less than 500.